lina sent me a question how do i  authenticate calls to my cloud run  service  well it depends one if your service is a  web or mobile app backend and you need  to validate the user  use firebase authentication send the jaw  token from your client and validate it  in your cloud run service  two if your service is a backend but you  don't want to validate the jot token in  your code  consider api gateway three if your  service should only be reachable from  other services in your google cloud  project  set ingress to allow internal traffic  only  four if your service should only be  reachable from other services which  may run outside google cloud download a  key file from google cloud and set  require authentication five if your  service should only be reachable by  people in your organization set up a  load balancer  identity aware proxy and set ingress  accordingly  what are your google cloud serverless  questions post them in the comments